this show is sponsored by sea geek
seed geek makes it easier than ever to
buy and sell sports and concert tickets
our listeners get 20 off of their first
heat geek purchase this is all you have
to do you download the free sea geek app
you go to the settings tab and click on
ADD promo code and the promo code is
church and see geek will send you twenty
dollars after you've made your first
purchase so download download the free
seed geek app now and enter promo code
church today show is also brought to you
by datsusara go to dsgear.com for
extremely high quality functional gear
made with hemp textiles they have bags
Keys rash guards and more go to
dsgear.com right now and use code word
Joey to get five percent off of your
order and go to onnit.com and use cohort
Church to save 10 on all their great
optimization products like Alpha Brain
new mood streamtech immune and shroom
tech support
oh [__] [__]
it's a beautiful Monday afternoon
Monday June 13th the day the devil was
buried at Sea and stabbed in the neck
OJ's alive
what are you gonna do
it's the Church of What's Happening Now
[__]
Lee Syed
Matt Baker BJJ
and Uncle Joey here Direct on a Monday
smooth
[Music]
afternoon
oh [__]
you can't get by me [__]
you don't know these streets
[__]
what's the story that Lisa yeah oh this
is ah whatever these are these are
[__] great I told you oh my God we're
telling you you got to change it up from
time yeah we do that is the spice of
life man
it is a spice of life I went on a uh
Ferris wheel this weekend yeah
eat some ziti when you're in the [__]
Ferris wheel you have your little hat
with the balloon on the top [__]
Ferris wheel you know there's always a
by the way with you you know that well
it was great it was it Irvine yeah it
went to the carnival
unbelievable what I gotta deal with
grown man in the [__] Ferris wheel
I'm surprised you didn't bring home a
rash or a [__] dead eyebrow you put
the Jinx on me at the end of last week
you said I was gonna get a stye again I
got a stye last week oh you did yeah
right
that's something [__] up it always
happens the day of the podcast for me
and you always get it on like the
weekends that's messed up I know where
the [__] I got it from it went away I
put some cat piss on it whatever the
[__] you're supposed to put on and back
like [__] Doctor Omaha Nebraska was
great this weekend I just want to talk
about one thing uh give my heart out I
know my Baker feels the same and yes
lead to the victims in Orlando uh a
[__] disaster a [__] disaster you
know
uh do I have the answer does Matt have
the answer does Lee have the answer we
got Solutions and but nobody's gonna
listen nobody gives a [__] so it really
doesn't matter what we give a [__]
right now the important thing is that
the souls get to the right place
with godspeed and that they're blessed
and whatever the [__] comes with that
into the next world it's very sad that
we live there and uh you know because
the United States of America we pay
taxes we have the right to bear arms but
I never wanted that
I don't want that I don't want that you
know uh
I don't want to [__] go out like I
was when I was 22 with two guns strapped
to me for no [__] reason you know
like I said in my world a gun is a
[__] magnet that you know it's just a
magnet when you deal with guns you bump
into people with guns you know next
thing you know you're giving people hugs
and they have machine guns on their
[__] body and you sit there and go I
can't believe I'm in the [__] room
have you ever hugged somebody and you
felt a gun on them your body freezes
even if you know the person for 20
[__] years it's weird just to see a
gun just to see it on a person so like I
said yesterday when I landed at the
airport at 9 18 in the morning
I got in the cab
and as I was getting in the cab two guys
walked by me in military fashion with
two by two [__] rocket launches I
don't know what type of guns AR-15 I
wish I was an authority I'm guns but I'm
not
and before I left I looked to my left
and in the parking structures that's
what that dog with body armor on ready
to ride
it's the world we got to live in now are
you [__] kidding me but
we uh ate the hummus and now we gotta
deal with what comes with it you're
following me I mean the first time I was
really ever exposed to that was Israel
because they just had the Army
everywhere it's just they're they're
constantly patrolling and
honestly I felt pretty safe like it was
never like I never never you feel safe
yeah and I get it I feel safe too when I
see two cops and whatever but not really
because [__] Johnny had died could
come out of a car with a bomb strap and
just pull it right in the middle of the
terminal four
but you know what I wasn't born to see
[__] guns around me if not I would
have stayed in Havana [__] Cube and
had guards around me watching me do you
understand me and I tell you as kooky as
you people think Alex Jones is he told
me this six years ago and in 10 years
it's going to be uh TSA at parks
you're gonna have to metal detectors at
parks you know my wife and I were
talking today about I'll tell you who I
would be I'd be scared right now if I
was Las Vegas
yeah then our metal detectors at the
door guys
they're not metal detectors at the
[__] door
you know when I go to Vegas to relax
that's when I want to feel [__] safe
when I got three G's in my pocket I'm
playing blackjacks not that I even do
that I don't even play Blackjack I just
know how people get when they go to
Vegas you know they sit down they take
their money out they start drinking for
free a couple [__] sleeping pills and
you're just having a good time whatever
turns you on man don't you think they've
been like preparing since like 9 11 like
like just in me Vegas seems like the
place that would have to be fully always
on alert
well that's the city they want to get
they want to talk to like Larry it was
very uh in on that stuff it'll tell you
that that's the the city they really
want to get to because there's a lot of
money there's something that goes
through Vegas something
that they would love to shut Vegas's
lights out and let me tell you something
30 years ago Vegas was under scrutiny
and I I don't I never trusted Vegas and
I have stories to back those things why
I never trusted Vegas
but now they really got to be watching
I'm scared to jerk off in the [__]
shower in Vegas they're watching dog you
got to assume they're [__] watching
my Baker talk to me you [__] Savage
you true Jitsu Savage of debt I'm
entertained by this like it's just uh I
can kick back and just listen to you
guys no um when I was in New York it was
very interesting because they you know
Rockefeller Center I was there for a
tournament and it was kind of just an
eye-opener they had you know armed
police right there in the middle of
Times Square everything and um great
City but it's kind of a little
heartbreaking to the point where you
you're there to have fun and there's
guys with machine guns walking around it
puts like a [__] certain uh
like a cat's tail sticks up like a skunk
like he just didn't ruin your night it
doesn't ruin your night but you it stays
in the back of your mind and Jesus
Christ
I'm drinking down the block from two
guys dressed like they go in a [__]
War
you know two guys just walked past me
from time to time
people [__] inspire me sometimes it's
music sometimes it's a basketball player
sometimes it's a UFC fighter you know
again I was always baffled with Bruce
Lee as a child and I was there when he
was alive and I used to hear all the
talks and I used to go to Chinatown buy
all the booklets
and they used to talk about this jikun
doe [__] I'm not that it's [__] I'm just
saying he's talking about jikundo
and for years as a young man I thought
about what it took
to take what you thought was important
and sell it you know look at things and
go why don't you know it's like now in
grammar school did you guys all use a uh
uh compass in grammar school you know
the one that you put the stick in and
you spin around you did you use it yeah
did you use one to create a circle in a
circumference of a circle use it more
for drawing have you ever used the
[__] thing again
so if you were gonna start a school the
first thing you go is listen take that
compass and shove it up your [__] ass
I don't want those things in my car a
protractor protractor all that [__] you
know what I'm saying like there was just
so many things you learned in grammar
school right now that you as an adult
would go what would you do different
well you know I needed to know more
about geography I needed more know more
about English I needed to know more
about you know whatever but [__] social
studies or whatever you know something
that you didn't think was important to
you everybody has that
if you talk to anybody with me at comedy
if you said to me
do you think it's necessary for me to go
to a comedy school no I think I think
it's necessary for you to learn the
basics and then get on stage that's it
just get on stage I don't want to know
nothing I don't want to know are you
doing it's a two years let me see
yourself I don't want to see nothing
I've seen a thousand [__] sets
already all you need to do is get on
stage
to your [__] eyes pop up when is that
I have no idea I've been doing it for 25
years my eyes haven't popped out yet so
I don't [__] know
so I meet a guy like you
who's interesting to the [__] Max
because you're well behaved your mom
managed there's no [__] tattoos
you're a Christian you're very sweet
and you've you've gotten your black belt
under John job when did you join John
John when did you become
whatever would you Jitsu what year yeah
um I train
I trained two years before I went to
John jocks just bumping around just
trying to figure out something to make
things work and it was October of 96
that that I claimed that day that date
because it he used to give out these
cards and I remember getting October 96
is that and you would go in there and
they would like check it to make sure
you were official and uh you know so I
can claim that that particular time but
I think it was actually going there a
little bit I used to drive there and
train on Saturdays and um you know
that's that's probably where where I
would say was my official Machado run so
you've been a 20 year Machado yeah yeah
John John it's yeah it makes me feel old
you know thank you
time flies so yeah and when did you open
your own school
um to around 2003 it was kind of an
accident how it went but I'm glad it
worked out was there anybody else from
Bakersfield at that time teaching Jiu
Jitsu I think everybody at that time
they were trying to adopt Jujitsu like a
lot of schools were were you know you
would have a karate school that would
start a jiu jitsu program or a graph
they weren't calling it Jiu Jitsu
they're actually calling more like
grappling uh one person renamed his own
style of jujitsu and uh you know that
was kind of it was from a different
martial art it was just when it when it
hit and people were like this is the
thing to do
um you know it was you know it was how
can we make this work how can we
incorporate this in and you know so a
solid Jiu Jitsu school like what we see
today there wasn't really any of that
going on you know there wasn't any good
opportunities to train consistently
regularly so I would go to you know this
guy's house over here or go over there
and then try to oh over there that you
know they're doing a little bit of this
on Monday and maybe you know sometimes
they meet up on Friday so it was really
hard to find adequate training so the
answer was you know go to La you know or
go to one of the major Hub cities you
know and at the time it was kind of just
you know it was scaled down to the Bay
Area or Los Angeles area unfortunately
Bakersfield is not far from Los Angeles
so just drove over the Grapevine the
first place
fortunately the first place that was
really you know on the on on the radar
was uh was Tarzana and John Jackson
Tarzana so at the time hegan not Higgin
um hinato and NATO Magno who's a
gentleman that runs Street Sports now or
the professor of the master of the
street sports I don't know what what
he's calling himself but I would just
say Professor hinato Magno he was
actually
the first black belt that I was actually
getting a lot of instruction and then
John Jack would come in you know and he
would bounce around because he I think
they still had the Redondo Beach School
so you know keeping busy over there and
then going back and forth and then
shortly into the mix
I still remember John jack's first
lesson and uh
to to believe it or not I I'm visually I
remember what he taught but I'm thinking
he was even teaching it without it
without a ghee not that John Jack
teaches a nogi school or anything like
that but I think it was during the time
when he was kind of prepping towards Abu
Dhabi and that's when he had his great
moment in Abu Dhabi you know shortly
after we got most technical fighter and
choked everybody it's amazing that John
jock school is like Seattle
to my comedy career
because you guys have yourself Eddie
Todd and Austin uh there's a lot of
black belts that I hear about you know
the cop that hangs out with John you
know John Jack has a lot of black belts
that have done well on their own you
know or
I don't know uh so it's really weird
house with Seattle when I came from
Seattle was Brody Stevens and Josh wolf
and a bunch of us came down there's
still a bunch of us that are still here
and it's very it gives me a sense of
Pride that I'm affiliated with those
guys like I had Brody on last week I
talked to Josh every [__] day on the
phone
you know uh it's really weird when you
see the growth of you people like I
remember Eddie's saying once to me I
remember Alberta when he was a [__]
blue belt you know we used to hang out
at tournaments you know that to me
that's like wow like now Alberto has
three [__] Stripes you have a couple
stripes on your but like this to me is
like this Sunday this Saturday
it's my 25th year of doing comedy
nothing has bothered me more than this
date just because it's 25 50 a year you
know when you turn 50 men have a
breakdown no when you're 40 you're
supposed to have a breakdown no you know
you're supposed to have these breakdowns
in life nothing has affected me this
date on Saturday
probably means more to me than anything
in the world
and I would have felt the same way if I
had nothing going on just because I
didn't think I was going to do anything
with my life never mind 25 [__] years
when you look at your Jiu Jitsu career
you gotta say 20 [__] years
that means that if I gain 300 more
pounds and Matt Baker lets me get on top
of it you give Matt Baker 15 minutes
he'll figure out a way to choke me out
as patient as can be without even
breaking the sweat he'll move he'll do
this I could even start with both
[__] hands on his collar he'll even
give me the first choke and I guarantee
I don't know about that Matt Baker can
get out of it I guaran [__] to you
that's what a black belt is that's why I
bet my money on Nick Diaz that time Nate
did no that was awesome I respect
Jujitsu when I see in the beginning I
would drop on him people could just get
on top of me watch this and within three
minutes they were [__] choking me
with one hand then I would go
I would just fly like I'm breathing
heavy and I was on top I'm having a
nervous breakdown that was on top of you
you look at you you didn't even break a
sweat your gee your geese a little
messed up what about Javier Vasquez
putting you inside control on the floor
that time yeah and he's you're one like
100 pounds everything yeah and you
couldn't get up I'll try getting out of
my Baker cycle I give you a [__] five
dollars if you get a map Bakers you
think a buildings on top of you that's
what sticking with something is
sticking with something guys it's if
Matt bacon when you walked into John
jocks the truth and when you walked out
if if I came to you as an angel and goes
you will be here in 20 years getting a
visual would you beat the [__] out of me
go 20 years
20 [__] years Jiu Jitsu I ain't that
much of a [__] stiff would you
think that somebody came to you that day
and said you'd be doing this for 20
years having three successful schools
creating your own
world of Jiu Jitsu through Paris I mean
you're out there [__] hustling you're
out there hustling I look at your videos
and I take some before I go to Jujitsu I
put your videos on loud and as I'm
putting my knee pads on and my knee pads
like the Rocky theme yeah I put your
videos on I'm honored man thank you you
know and I take something and I go to
like you know when you taught me the
side control from 11 to 2
I forgot about putting my hip against
you know let me tell you something
if if I put my [__] side of my ass
against your face listen it's all over
it's all just just tap because within
three inches you're gonna be sniffing my
[__] you got about you got about four
minutes before that packet deconstructs
okay well that's the ex that's the other
part of the move I was going to tell you
oh please and that hit that hip side
that hip side changes everything it
changes everything looks like arithmetic
you're just waiting it's like you're
going fishing just breathe and stay on
top of the guy he's gonna go he did and
he's gonna try to get you off and all of
a sudden eventually your hand goes
through his arm and you've got it it's
like stealing you didn't even do nothing
and next thing is now part two next time
we work together is picking them oh and
he picks you up Lee and he puts his
pressure on you he crushes his knees and
he pushes that belt against your [__]
back feel like you're like he's got it
man but I can't I don't have it yet so
next time we work together we're gonna
do part two I'm gonna tell you right now
you nailed it actually give yourself
credit well the system your system that
slow movement constant pressures keeping
him thinking you know I look at some of
your videos that listen
this is like Jew type [__] you know what
Lee they can't pass you back if you're
not on your back
right now you know what this
[__] said they can't pass you
God if you're not on your back yeah
that's true where are you supposed to be
on your [__] on your threes holding
on to his sleeves so when he goes to
pull up to go away from me you pop grab
his leg you drop your hip he goes down
you got him in a [__] third League
this is something made for a little you
hit him with the alligator footley it's
all over Lee's got alligators
up a new video oh my God he whips him up
and listen to Lee it's just he pulls
you're with fat dudes he's pulling you
up lee lee he's pulling us up so he's
breathing already now you clamp onto his
leg like it's a [__] rib this system
was invented for fat dudes you just
clamp on like this and you just you have
that foot between his leg you put it
next to his anger and you go
it's over now now is when you got to
work you gotta get on top and huff and
puff a little bit but if you stick to
Matt Baker's system it's all over but
the shouting for fat dudes and dudes you
don't want to fly Tomatoes unite that
you know he's got a side control bait
that Lee it's like you're next to him
about the comb his head
when he goes up he opens his leg like a
[__] Cosby victim you slip your leg
out boom you're in [__] mouth Lee
this [__] is [__] simple I'm [__]
and I'm telling you this from you know
these people go you'll get these white
butts that come to your class and also
like I've never done Jiu Jitsu before
I've lost in the black belt like ah he's
got him freaking because people watch
videos I can't learn like that he's made
videos
that I could learn
that's a [__] video
you know you have like the leglock 101
I'm not ready for all that [__] I ain't
gonna lie to you that's too complex for
me I don't even need it yeah I don't
need it right now I don't need it you
teach it to me and I know how to avoid
it but I don't need it and this is what
I'm saying people sometimes there's
people who Translate
something to the tiniest degree that you
go oh [__] it's like Pacino in that
football movie
takes the kid out and he goes listen
it's five o'clock
your mom's calling you for dinner you
got one more play left remember
go to the car and turn I'm gonna throw
it to you right by the Black Cadillac
it's that simple we in life take
everything and we make it so complicated
from A to Z myself included I'm a stress
cast bro why do you think I smoke weed
for any [__] pounds Edibles because
my mind is going all [__] day
he's made a system that is so [__]
easy you know we worked together for 45
minutes I go home that day I got a jiu
jitsu magazine in the mail I bumped into
the guy gave me a free subscription I
open up there's a picture you I'm
[__] blown away I'm blown away you
know and then I turned my computer on
like a [__] Periscope I don't listen
I ain't gonna lie no but I don't have a
Chrome on my computer I don't know how
to turn it on between us I don't want it
done
Chrome just gets [__] in
trouble you know what I'm saying you get
Chrome and then now you're seeing [__]
that you're not supposed to see so you
can't catch your Periscope on the
computer
I gotta catch it on the phone so
sometimes I'm out you know well thank
you well
that whole I'm new to all this Periscope
stuff to be honest with you the future
yeah if you're not doing jumping jacks
on Periscope and you're a fitness
trainer you're slipping yeah
if you're not showing them your little
diet in the morning you're slipping
people want to be involved people
remember when we were kids Jacqueline
used to come up in the morning at nine
and you do jumping jacks with Jacqueline
and the whole country the jet people
will do that again if you give them a
good product if you tell people listen
to 10 to 11 I'm gonna come on Paris Club
let's do a 45 minutes Kettlebell workout
you know what
within a month people gonna call you and
say listen
I'm coming to your house with a [__]
check
and my [__] kid and my fat [__]
wife you're training everybody there's a
call that's our nomination yeah it's
amazing when you give to somebody from
your heart you're giving when you do
those periscopes with the Mexican hats
and [__] music
I'm a [__] cop I understand me I'm a
criminal I watch everything I watch a
person ten things at once well can I say
why this whole thing started okay well
first of all inspired by you because you
you are the king of periscope okay so
let's just Brody Stevens I come in
second
well I gotta say this man you you
inspire a lot of people you guys
describe man and well the whole deal is
you know I uh I'm I'm gotta admit I'm
catching up to this because you know I'm
in my 40s I'm going to use that as an
excuse and at that age you're you're
just trying to stay above water with all
the technology stuff coming up so I
started doing the Periscope thing but
the main thing that I wanted was I
wanted people to be able to ask me
questions of me to answer and it kind of
started off that way and it got to the
point I had a lot of material to work
with like okay cool I can answer this
all right I'll answer that because what
I want is I want people to have the
answer to these Concepts because
realistically the videos most videos
if they're not flashing they kind of get
overlooked but the whole thing is the
Simplicity is why it's successful the
things that that I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to solve the stuff that happens
all the time to people and there's
always an answer so the whole Periscope
thing was intended for people to be able
to to ask a question and me just route
off the answer real quick and that's
what I wanted people to see happen but
um you know the questions come in a
little bit slower and then the jokes go
up a little bit higher so just trying to
you know someone told me not to be too
serious and then
now my daughter's telling me to be a
little bit more serious because I'm
embarrassing her so it almost makes me
want to try harder to embarrass her but
maybe how old are your daughters my my
daughter Boomerang Kylie it was 17.
going on Periscope or they watch them I
put her on Periscope um I have one of
the trujitsu gis is actually named after
her and uh you know so I you know I have
fun with that like any dad would do I
have a lot of I put a little hinted
hidden notes and stuff you know so
sometimes people might be doing a move
that's actually named after you know one
of my kids and they don't realize it you
know and it's just it's it's an inside
joke but it's fun and the people that
know about it they you know they like oh
man you know you got to assume this is
an intelligent person which you're very
intelligent you have to assume
that your periscopes yeah they inspire a
dude like me but what you're really
doing is
there's two guys in South Dakota that
are 160 miles from a [__] Brazilian
yeah never minded Jujitsu school you
know what I'm saying and you if you say
I'm gonna do Periscope from 8 30 to 9
30.
these guys will put [__] geese on and
get mats in their house and you inspire
them like that
you're not doing this for the 300 that
you think it's the 20 people that don't
have to get us and that comes back to
you in spades
if you tell people I'm gonna be there at
nine o'clock after I teach my [__]
hour and a half class and get beat up by
[__] purple belts and do an arm bar
80 times for the 80th [__] time I'm
gonna get on here and work with you guys
for 30 minutes
you're going to help a lot of people and
it's amazing that eight years from now
you're going to be the tournament some
guy's gonna go you know why I learned
that after you see them tap something
that's yes the real heart's gonna
[__] stop you're gonna go Jesus
I learned that on Periscope someday a
UFC fighter is going to get his hand
raised Joe Rogan is going to interview
him and where'd you learn that crucifix
that way I've seen it from different
variations are you Russian no some
[__] Professor from Bakersfield Matt
[__] Baker BJJ rocking the [__]
yeah well I that's you know it becomes
an art like
you know going back 20 years I didn't
think it was going to be like this yeah
no you hit it right on the nail I I just
was you know and I I even had a couple
people take say some it's funny because
like one guy was telling me you're you
know okay because I had a good moment in
class this is 20 years ago okay and then
uh he he was you know he was one of the
guys that was training with me he goes
okay you did good but you know you're
just not ever going to be great at this
you know you just gotta understand that
you just there's you're too old and I
wasn't even really old back then you
know but the whole thing it was kind of
something that I was like okay you know
I'm just gonna be okay you know and I'm
but the whole thing is that you know I'm
not saying I'm great now I'm not saying
I'm smart that wasn't what I was trying
to get at but what I was basically
implying is that
20 years ago I didn't plan on you know
things being where they are yeah it does
I'm very thankful who the [__] does so
so I didn't even plan on you know
winning anything or ever having
successful moments but you know things
have been a blessed you know it's been
things have been really cool and I'm
thankful for it so so it's more of an
art now like now I just you know now
that I have this fun thing I'm like how
far can it go you know so
here we are and like because to me I'm
like I'm like five years in I guess to
my career
and to think about 25 years in your life
[__] 20 years you they had gender
of pillow rubbing your feet and [__]
I got you out here you're a new animal
who wouldn't want a few foot rubs but
anyways like eating ziti and brownies
who just made me brownies but no walnuts
really two thousand dollars
nuts ruin brownies the [__] guys
plain brownies are you crazy walnuts
walnuts are the worst two thousand miles
two ways he comes back with ziti and
[__] brownies that's what I want and
that's going on no clams there's a
hundred clams waiting to [__] come to
California you tell people not to eat
hummus you want me to bring like stinky
clams on a plane no you got a luggage
for 25 bucks you throw it away you go to
Kmart you got a piece of luggage you put
the clams in there you put some ice
cubes in there with [__] uh the
people at the airport open up like this
dude is the real [__] deal they
don't know what's in your suitcase they
don't give a [__] it's just six hours
you get off the plane we bring them
right to the house we clam break those
things you show up with ziti and fukaj
[__] brownies with no nuts in them
and [__] if some kid lit down analogy
he'd even be upset that's ruling
brownies I'll stop I'll say that till
the end but it I can't believe I even
remember what it's gonna say
um that's just shocking
15 more years seems crazy like I I can't
even you can't fathom no that's what
nobody I got it listen 25 years ago I
was [__] lost guys I had a wife
I had a an 18 month old kid maybe I
don't know what she was at the time
maybe 18 months
and I decided to finally get on [__]
stage it took me six [__] months my
baby
of calling and canceling
I'm sick my mother died my grandmother
died my great it was horrible I was so
scared yeah you're nervous oh it was
every it wasn't nerves let me tell you
what it was thinking back
I got to be honest with you about one
thing
I knew it was going to change my life
there was eight percent of Me no no I'm
lying to you there was 10 of me that I
think I was hoping it would change my
life
you know what I'm saying like I'm not
gonna so were you scared to do it
because you were absolutely okay
absofucking little you're comfortable as
a as a human beings we get comfortable
we come in this [__] Zone I just came
out of prison you know the back of my
head I knew about my history the back of
that I knew about I had no future
I knew what I was
and I was hoping that maybe maybe Matt
Baker
just maybe this could
slow me down if I stopped smoking Coke
eight nights a week and go to three if I
stopped thinking about robbing people if
I stop thinking about going back to New
Jersey and quitting this [__] and just
becoming a crim it was just terrible
and I said something to my wife at the
time
and a day later she goes I gave the baby
to
my mother that night so I'll be able to
go with you we had not been on a date in
[__] a year you know
you know I was working on a roof in the
daytime
and I was I just quit my uh at night I
was working as a doorman at a comedy
club and I got to tell you man big I
hated my [__] life I was doing
everything I could I was trying Buddhism
I made my confirmation who makes that
confirmation I'm in a room every Tuesday
night with 10 [__] 10 year olds
talking about Jesus like a [__]
pervert all I need is a rain jacket and
I get three years you know what I'm
saying that's all I need I swear to God
I went back and took CID study Catholic
Youth Organization Tuesday nights with a
priest and eight [__] kids that were
10 trying to learn that confirmation
there I am a big dope sitting at one of
the little kid desks no no you went to
the church and he would talk from the
from the thing I hope it and you do the
study there you know
and then Monday nights I would go to uh
not in the Rope Institute I keep saying
the Rope I used to go on the road but
for other things on Saturdays for
readings and [__] but on Monday nights I
would go up to the mountains to
Chautauqua and they'd do walking
meditation the stinkiest white people
you ever met in your [__] life okay
they haven't taken showers in years
but at the time Matt Baker that's how
lost I was it's funny because
today they were talking about how quick
the FBI has a thing now how long it
takes to get what's the word when you go
from 0 to 60 and you become a full-out
radical there's a word for the
transformation when you radicalize or
something like that um and they were
talking about how things have to be
happening in your life for something
like that to enter and make sense you
know what I'm saying like you go through
a divorce your kid don't want to talk to
you you know your dog got hit by a car
your job puts you on part-time you know
your week all sudden you're mad at
Hillary or something you're mad at
Donald Trump and next thing you know
you know next thing you know you're
[__] eating in the hummus and some
dudes whispering in your ear I got the
answer you know what I'm saying and all
of a sudden it sticks and I can't
believe that that time at my life
nothing was sticking God forbid 10
people would have showed up with
Bazookas and so let's take over a
country because your life's not I mean
that's how weak I was mentally looking
back at that and as much as I hate this
woman
I thought about how she put me on the
spot she had already made a commitment
to give the kid to a mother and she had
already made plans she was excited so
now my balls are held to the wall guy I
couldn't back out now
so at that moment I [__] ran that
Judy Carter book and I wrote [__]
three minutes of material
and I still remember driving down there
what we drove you know what I felt like
because I knew I was going to walk
through a new [__] door
but I didn't want to in a way you know
what I'm saying like I didn't want to
and uh Matt Matt Woods was the headliner
that night it was an open mic and I was
going to ask you if you still remember
like your whole
yeah not even close at that time or
something about Godzilla
I think something stupid about him
coming out of the Hudson I think I'm not
even sure at that time
if I had developed that and I went up
there for three minutes and when I got
off I got great applauses
the club said I had good presence
and how to work my material and Matt
Woods came over he was a long island guy
and he was like keep coming back here
there's something there you know
and I've been believing them like in
shock like physical [__]
physical psychological spiritually
like I have arrived like I got baptized
that was it were you worried you were
gonna bomb is that what you're most
worried about or are you worried that
you're gonna do well
I was worried I was going to find the
ends with all my problems
and while I was there before I left some
guy got me a gig for five bucks thank
that guy and I went and did that gig and
did well
and then I was just walking on a cloud
now I I didn't know what to do or how to
do it I just knew what I wanted to do
so I think I went up again in August
at a Denver Bronco function
vagina wouldn't show up so it was just
the other [__] Broncos some rookies
and [__] up in Greeley it stunk like
death up there but the guy got me two
gigs I did that gig then I got another
gang for like 50 bucks so it was just
really amazing and then September was
when I cracked
and my wife said you should go back to
New York and see what you want to do and
I went to New York and I went to do
comedy but I didn't do comedy one time I
did everything about [__] comedy
and I went to the clubs at night and
just watched the open mics and I it
scared the [__] out of me
I went back to Colorado and then as I
got to Colorado the local paper I had a
contest a comedy contest
and how can I laugh about that people
were calling me up going hey man go down
and I'm like [__] and I was like [__] do
you think it was a mistake to go to New
York she just stayed in Colorado
for those two weeks no I had not been
back to New York for six years it's
really weird how your life works out I
had not been back to New York for six
years I was turned off complete I didn't
want to go back to Jersey I never wanted
to see those people again
but at that point I was so [__] lost
I said let me go back there and walk
those streets
I ended up going back I'm kind of
hooking up with my stepfather seeing my
friends and I broke the news to them and
they kind of laughed in my face you know
what I'm saying like I'm gonna try
stand-up comedy and I'm like oh that's
great do another line of coke you know
what I'm saying like we were just
partying that and all of a sudden I
dropped it on them
and I went back home and I contest and I
won the first round I think I won the
second round and then I got my wife I
went home one afternoon
and my wife had found the loan Matt
Baker that I took but I paid real quick
it was to flip a car
and she wanted to get separated
and I was like
Matt Baker I heard you know those when
you see uh movies and Jesus shows up you
hear those organs and [__]
it was something like I love my child
but this was what was in my way the
whole time I knew it I knew I didn't
want to be [__] married
not the HUD it was not the nap there was
nothing there was two kids who evolved
and became something else and then
realized
the same for me for the rest of our
lives but now we got this kid then
whatever happened happened
but this whole week I've been struggling
with the fact that I don't know what
made me stuck with it
like when she left I was [__]
Brokenhearted
and
I just kept getting on stage then I met
girls and I did drugs and but next thing
you know I was getting calls for gigs
guys
not big money gigs I'm not like the
Improv I mean [__]
Lee you would giggle the play Jimmy
abatea used to get me [__] gigs
everywhere for 40 bucks
like a bars or something like a bar but
I had gotten the every Tuesday night for
the first year this is what saved me
every Tuesday night I had to go on stage
and come up with new material
that saved me I had that job for 18
months that turned me into that kind of
that's like going somewhere
two times a week enrolling for an hour
with a black belt you'll get good
because there's certain things you got
to do in that room it's the same [__]
customers
it's the same people it was 15.95 and
you got a steak on a baked potato
and [__] you got a comedy ticket same
type of people went every week to get
the [__] 1595 State because it was
really a thirty dollars that's during
the week so that's a lot of pressure
because
if you're not coming up with something
new oh we should have it oh yeah I
remember one time I put on the Madonna
cones
way before you or even thought in your
dad's past this is 19 the one were you
born 88 oh and so you were five Madonna
was huge in 92.
but she did one song where she had cones
on it today yeah remember that and I
came out with them please tell me you
have a picture because no no that would
be great of me and Madonna no no Madonna
please come on no I came out with the
cones on my pitch it was just a year and
what saved me was that my friends would
come to the show and they would giggle I
had a really like I knew people I lived
in bowls I went to prison in Boulders
I knew [__] though
I went to prison I did that's when they
locked me up you want me to lie to you
it's just the things that we stick with
so do people well okay so in the process
of writing now like this is kind of
interesting so you know how do you how
do you come up with material now I mean
was it observational observational yeah
you know I mean it just kind of
it would seem like the more you're
exposed to stuff the easier it probably
gets right well you have so many stories
and it's just kind of like okay the
second your life is probably the easier
it is to come up with stuff well yeah
yeah yeah because you meet yourself so
you look at things from a different
perspective it's like last week the
[__] gorilla you know everybody you
know I was thinking about that [__]
gorilla house you know what look at that
gorilla he ain't a normal gorilla that's
a [__] gorilla like he ain't right
if you if you have kids and you go to a
zoo in the country right now well you
got [__] up gorillas I tell you I'm
telling you I've been dumb people on
stage they're awful we China gets the
best gorillas China pays top dollar for
gorillas for 15 mil 20 mil so they get
the best and the reason why these are
endangered because they're [__]
there's not a lot there's not a lot of
them left that's why they're in danger
because we got their [__] [__]
Apes they stick their finger in their
ass and sniffing in front of your 10
year old how do you know when that to
your 10 year old yeah they throw [__] at
each other those are a ton of gorillas
dog gorillas are intelligent you ever
see a line in the zoo he's been shot two
times they got him with his his Bush he
got flies everywhere go to [__] China
look at the [__] the [__] lions in
China they combed they got nice teeth
everybody's [__] happy you're crazy
we get bummy [__] animals we get
bummy [__] out go to LA Zoo go to LA
Zoo I haven't even been oh first off
it's all up pill so you got to be Johnny
[__] shake to go to LA Zoo you got to
be in shape or you got to take a train
that goes a mile an hour you rather
shoot yourself and then they play the
same [__] song over and over with
some dude you know who's getting 650 an
hour and he's about ready to take that
train back to Mexico you can tell you
can tell he's like I'm taking this train
back to Mexico okay serious Mexican I
don't know it could be anything I'm just
saying he could be anything but it's a
[__] my wife's like I gotta keep mine
yeah you got to keep your eyes open at
the zoo cause I'll tell you what I'm not
even a terrorist and there's times I got
another zoo and I want to shoot
everybody I swear to God the Apes the
cause they're all [__] up at those
lose I went to the zoo in Big Bear and
it's it's all animals that have been
like
rescued to like this is like a
three-legged bear it's like it's the it
was kind of crazy but did you know this
was actually really weird China owns all
pandas
even if a panda is born Here China owns
it yeah but guess what even that pan is
[__] up I guarantee the pandas we got
over here they're all [__] up the
pandas they got over there nice they
[__] smell like cotton
I don't know my baby you know what I'm
saying I'm just trying to tell you no
well that was pretty Yeah man so just
good perspective yeah no it's true you
have to look at things sometimes I look
at things because I know we're getting
bullshitted you gotta assume 70 of the
media is bullshitting is scaring you
you know
listen when the report first came out of
Orlando he had called whatever and then
it got deeper and deeper and deeper
God knows
you sit there and you sit there
yesterday I sat there for 45 minutes
watching CNN you know
thinking about people I know and I don't
know in situations I mean Felipe was
there
was there in Orlando at the [__]
Resort I have an aunt who lives there
and you know Damon's father's there God
did it that's like somebody shooting
somebody down the corner like that yeah
well I can't eat guys you can't when a
person dies
you could feel that person's spirit in
the neighborhood for a couple days
before that person gets buried
that person is not gonna [__] leave
you could feel it in the air something's
wrong my mom died of rain for a few days
in Jersey cloudy weather you could feel
it
then the Sun comes out and everything
moves can you imagine
what that smells like over there right
now with the gunpowder and
you could smell the death in the air if
any City doesn't deserve that have you
ever been to Orlando I mean listen it's
not Johnny glam
whatever but [__] Disneyland
this kid should have to see all those
cops it's just a horrible [__]
disaster you know what's going on right
now but it's the world war violent on
there's nothing you could do what's Tony
Bennett you got upset though oh we
haven't been doing so I'm saying you're
[__] slipping here this is a perfect
Tony Bennett talk I apologize I know
what you're thinking we haven't been
doing to anybody I know you've been
slipping lately that's what I'm saying
you do a star of death and you think
about ziti
my bacon is very great to have you on
here it's a privilege to be here man so
I uh it takes balls
well here we go do a little swing and
pop up make believe you got the [__]
hat on though baby I can't wear the hat
now yeah
I don't think I watched you think I'm
some [__] Johnny come lately I I
gotta pay attention Pedro's got another
plan B yeah
I like the music
in the Periscope oh one Periscope you
told him to turn it down it sounds good
no I have
it's all inspired it's all for a purpose
you got a good idea and I know what your
heart is
so it's like yeah what made you come up
with that name
well
the the whole
see this is the whole deal
when
when you know back to 20 years ago and
never really thought I was going to get
anywhere with you Jiu Jitsu was just
something I was hoping to do
and uh
you know I Had My Moments where things
were good and things were bad but the
irony is is that when I had the best
moments is when my actual body declined
and uh you know I had a neck injury
and that neck injury was something that
I was kind of encouraged not to do Jiu
Jitsu anymore so it was like well I
think you should stop you know and you
know that's really not an option when
you have a school there's there's just
no way you're gonna you know be able to
not roll
so uh
Concepts that kind of were forced I just
basically was pushed you know I think
all good things you know happened for a
reason and uh you know it was one of
these things where
my neck was giving me a lot of problems
and uh it was forcing me to basically
went you know to use my brain more so uh
a lot of Concepts I started using
basically to get by for
you know the lack of ability of being
physical so I mean I've never been a
natural athlete I would never say like I
was you know all the years of judicial
no one ever said that I was strong or I
was you know very you know athletic or
whatever
um so not that I was ever physical but
you know the better moments where I
actually was healthy and I was in better
shape you know I would have some wins
some losses and then you know every once
in a while things were you know there
was some good moments but then
what ended up happening was you know uh
it got to the point where I really
couldn't even do a push-up because this
neck was bothering me which you know the
same thing like Chris White and what
he's going through you know his so I
guess he's got to get surgery he had it
all right yeah it's a pretty common
thing because you know wrestlers you
know they're pushing with their neck and
I would say I was actually probably
being more physical in my earlier you
know ways of playing Jiu Jitsu but
being forced to rearrange your movement
it actually opened up a whole new
perspective as far as and and to be
honest with you it wasn't like all of a
sudden at once it was like a
cumulatively probably over the last
five maybe even I think you know it's
been a while but years I was like I
remember when I used to do this
and this was easier for me and I didn't
really
you know and I didn't really have a bad
moment I was playing this way and then
and then I had another season you know
because you have these moments where
things are going well for you and then
things are going bad and it really what
it boils down to is it's trial and error
it's it's a situation where you're you
know every time you're rolling you're
basically
if you're playing correctly you're bit
you're seeing what works and what
doesn't work and
you know when my body failed my brain
was kind of forced to kick in and then
that's where these Concepts came in that
you know I said well this isn't really
something that's physical it's not
really something that's uh that I'm
gonna have to go lift weights to do and
slowly but surely I started getting
encouragement from some close people and
friends and everything and you know we
have a certain way that we're doing
stuff that's that's kind of different so
that's where this kinesiology-based
movement and and ways of playing you
know came about so you start getting all
these all this information and you know
and I also ref too I've been roughing
yeah
and that's another reason why
I know you're not [__] around because
you're looking at it for more
perspectives yeah I know you're
reference look at that guy putting his
work there oh [__] yeah and you want to
even yell pick that armpit no I I've
actually done that like you know if you
sent me something like you know what
because I sometimes your heart goes out
to these people because they they're
they're so good at Jiu Jitsu like some
people are you know if you want to be
you know if you want to be amazed by by
Jiu Jitsu watch watch juveniles watch
watch kids because you get a kid that's
been training since he's you know he's
12 years old he's in train since he's
five that's seven years seven years of a
heart that won't stop
um no physical you know they're flexible
I mean they don't have no physical
Hang-Ups they're they're not sore they
go constantly and then when they start
doing moves you know they they move some
of them move so efficiently it's like
they are more entertaining than adults I
mean that's that's a very you know I'm
not the first person that said that but
I was roughing at a tournament uh
yesterday all day saw amazing matches oh
my goodness so sometimes you see people
do amazing Jiu Jitsu and still lose but
the reason why is not because of
you know the a skill issue is because
they're approached because they move too
much they they didn't position
themselves they were going from one
thing to another to another to another
and realistically when it comes right
onto it
you know sometimes the best thing is not
to move the best thing is just to chill
out you have a position
don't do one thing if it's not going to
just be for you if you're moving but it
gives them a chance
then that's kind of the biggest thing
with Jujitsu like
you know I
I basically have a lot of moves it's
somewhat are simple but the whole
purpose of I mean when you when you have
someone in 11 and two
uh you know do you do they what
opportunities are you giving them
you know I mean we want to that's you
know we went over that and we we just
briefly went away I've had
lighter guys that now just from the 11
to two if I do it correctly if they're
moving a lot it's so weird how
sometimes you go to a class and you have
an answer
and I put you on and you just gave me
the answer one day I left and I didn't
do something right it was that I didn't
hold the power with the hand
and then I watched that tape and I went
to class the next day and I got into 11
to 2 and I shifted my hip and as soon as
I shifted my hip Lee he put his hand up
to push boom I trapped it
no I had to pull him up now I trapped it
and I settled it no it's exactly yeah I
stayed there and I settled let him go to
pull the arm or pick him up I picked one
leg up slowly that's the point I'm
getting at it's like what would happen
if if you
picked up the arm and threw your leg
over the head and then went back when
they fell back from the arm would that
have given him a window to maybe get out
absolutely that's the whole that's a
[__] so so I look at the whole thing
once I grab the arm I'm so excited I'm
huffing and puffing myself and through
anxiety do you understand yeah and
that's what you learned you learn to
calm yourself down get a good grip on it
get your hands all right and this is
what I'm applying to Comedy yeah I can't
stress it enough I am every time I go
somewhere in a week and listen this week
I went to Omar Friday first show I was
menza
Friday's second show was a little better
Saturday for sure I was really good but
Friday a Saturday second show it was
[__] different level
different [__] level comedy and I
didn't like the weekend I knew I was
gonna have a problem on Friday because I
didn't get up on stage on Thursday
didn't have a Thursday if I would have
gone on stage Thursday I would have done
an hour loosened up see what parameters
I could push and then take it from there
my point being that Saturday night I was
doing Jiu Jitsu on stage
it was really weird I kept catching
myself in different situations but I was
breathing my way out of them
once you you know you read all these
things about if you control your
relaxation you control your fear [__]
hate you do
[__] hey you're doing Dr Balise is
coming back in a few weeks like in two
or three weeks I'm trying to nail it
down she's coming but she wants to come
back on about acid reflux
it was so weird doing her thing she was
talking about if you just shut your
mouth and relax your jaw and breathe out
of your nose automatically lowers your
blood pressure and something else she
was saying that's [__] amazing yeah
[__] amazing and when somebody my
size is laying on you that's all you got
to do is breathe it out a little bit
wait till I go for an arm wait for me to
make a mistake basically you know you're
not gonna move me you just want to burn
yourself out moving me you might get a
little better position but by that time
you're huffing and puffing I'm just
laying on you even more in side control
you know see these those type of
Concepts so they don't happen on
accident it's like observation
experience like see the whole Jujitsu I
don't even you know the funny thing is I
still have a hard time explaining if
it's a system or you know what and
that's the whole deal it's because it's
your art yeah it's the art that you made
to work for you and you know what some
kid who's 22 might go to your school
he'll love you Professor Baker but he
wants to do flying [__] Baron bolos
and I know in some of you like in the
101 leglock you're going through Z guard
once you're going through a z guard and
stuff like that you know I'm 25 years
old
six foot one 185 I got aspirations but
I'm not telling you yeah and you get
those guys they have aspirations but I'm
not telling you when I walk in here for
the first time I'm just an office guy
you know I'm just mumbling along like
meanwhile I'm jerking off every time he
sees Randy Couture yeah so he comes in
no it's the truth Hey listen man I was
jerking off when I'd see Eddie Murphy
was coming to town it's the same concept
I went to see Jerry Seinfeld and you
come in
and next thing you know maybe Professor
um he wants to do uh
Baron bolos and more uh yeah excogs and
more uh flying through the [__] air
and he's gonna last six months and he's
gonna he's gonna take something from
what you learned yeah but he wants to go
to something like that everybody has a
different style yeah
you know when you're a kid you take
Shotokan you take ishin roo you take
good shinru you take Russian Roux you
take Okinawa you say you know what at
the end of the [__] week you're doing
the same punches and the same [__]
kicks some but you what you're learning
is what that guy learned from his 20
years of experience
cut the fat out of a lot of [__] because
he knows what the percentage rate is the
first time yeah first time you and I
spoke you spoke about something that you
talked to me I'm a basketball player
listen a dunk is 100 move when I'm a
team I'm in Africa looking for seven
foot eight dudes listen come here oh I
want you to do is get the ball and slam
it okay I'm gonna give you 20 million a
year you can do the whole family over no
more shooting people for milks okay no
more nothing we're gonna [__] do this
right I just know Sky hooks I just want
you to take the ball and who's ever in
front of you I want you to slam it like
that come and shoot your family for
diamonds
okay that's it this is [__] it so
that's what you when you spoke to me
that morning about percentage I go oh
this [__] guy is coming at me from my
language well I'd see the whole thing is
I want people that are on look one guy
came one of my buddies Justin one of the
students he uh training Partners I'm
gonna call him he said beta's unite and
it was so funny because the concepts of
jujitsu you know they're good for
everybody I mean if you're an athlete so
be it you know but what I don't want
people to feel is that they have to do
CrossFit or they have to lift weights or
they have to do a bunch of athletic you
know athletic training to be good at Jiu
Jitsu because there is a way to move
that negates all of the strength and all
the athleticism of somebody and uh I'm
laughing Professor not laughing at you
know I saw something I'm laughing
because I tell you why Professor okay so
tomorrow myself
to you tomorrow okay I want you to look
at Lisa at least I had wrestled in high
school
just to breathe okay
if Lee takes you down
on uh I'm gonna take down and by mistake
because this kid wouldn't hurt himself
he lands with that [__] little horse
we showed there is I think they threw
these Jews on their shoulders and their
shoulders got strong all over
civilization when this [__]
lands on you Lee how many times that tap
when you landed on me dog he's a bull
his shoulder would go into your solar
plexus and you'd see Saints and [__]
okay when you see this kid okay now look
at him Lee's a strong kid
but look I love you to death in that
bank about it if you can spend hours
teaching him a reverse show his [__]
legs he got the legs of a [__] fidget
he's not going nowhere he can't even
wrap his legs around nobody so let's
teach him to move like Bruce Lee said
what's the easiest thing for him take
the Dude down shove that shoulder in his
thing spin him around grab that little
arm and come over just put him in the
corner yeah for a month you teach them
how to choke but you're wasting your
time his percentage of getting that
choke with his legs before the guy grabs
that alligator foot and panics and Taps
is [__] quick okay if he grabs you
from the back he will pop your head off
your shoulders Lee's a strong
[__] he's Young when he grab you
by the ghee and [__] just Manhattan but
I have T-Rex arms I can't joke no no no
but those arms are Jiu Jitsu perfect
ain't nobody on barring you they gotta
bring stilts the [__] armed by you
unless they got an extension
foreign
so that's a nightmare the only thing
they can do is come over here good luck
good luck if you hold on to that little
Kimura arm look at it your arm is
anti-ju Jitsu they can't grab look at
those things
so Lee has strengths and that's the
beauty of my Jujitsu Lee's not gonna
choke you out with that but he's gonna
get two moves
and you know what you're gonna win the
worlds with those two moves
like those classes oh yeah you're a neon
belly with that little knee too I don't
know what they did over there but they
toughened those joints up over DNA I
don't know what they did
you bad [__] you but it's so
weird that that's what you've created
you've created a system that's very one
two three and if you do this just like
this this is gonna happen eventually
yeah that well that you know going back
to that the young kid that you know
wants to do the fancier moves
you know there's there's a lot of
training partners that I have that they
do that but
Simplicity is where you're going to find
your success
and you know part of the problem with
with the modern Jiu Jitsu game is it's
based on your grips
you know your arm
it's like a chain so this is one link
your elbow is the other link
your fingers are the you know the
smallest links
so you know let's just break it down to
a science if you had to carry something
really heavy
what part of the chain is going to fail
you
fingers so why play a game against an
athlete that is amazing
that's going to be relying on the
smallest part the smallest Links of the
chain
so you know and that's kind of a simple
thing that I that you know with with a
lot of people that play that that's what
I just try to tell them you know so
that's going to be so if you're going to
play that game you got to know when to
cut and run when it's not working quit
doing the same thing
when the person's moving too much first
of all when they're standing up they
have a lot of Mobility
you know guard players have the
advantage because they have four limbs
pointed up as opposed to someone on top
who just has two that you know
realistically you're not even supposed
to be reaching so that's the reason why
jiu jitsu's turn into a guard players
game because there's so many guard
Concepts but at the same time
you know they it was a meme that just
came out
someone put it out with a Jaws eating
the guy when he's on a boat did you see
that one no yeah and it was it was
basically I saw that yeah when playing
open guard goes wrong but realistically
there's so many Dynamics when you play
open guard when you play these you know
so so true Jitsu has Concepts that you
know what I was going to say is a couple
of those flashing moves that I put I'm
actually there's going to be a two-part
process I showed you know a leg lock
recently called a 661 but
you know a lot of people kindly the 101
is beautiful yeah
simple yeah yeah and you're not giving
normally that would be a bad move see
because the one of the biggest traits of
Jiu Jitsu is every move that you do
counts for you
not them and if if you're doing a move
that gives them an opportunity then
that's not a true move and you know and
that's that's one of the things that I
you know that's a reason why things are
scaled down to Simplicity that's the
reason why it's mostly the most
important position for you to get is
taking someone's back so the deeper you
know someone goes into this these Jiu
Jitsu Concepts that's generally where
where I'm going to take them I'm going
to say you know this is where we want to
be we want to take someone's back or we
want to come more of them but right
after the kamorik is the backtake that
would be the next phase of where where
that
Joe if we end up keep if we in back in
that situation again that's the next
thing we're going over is how to take
the back and uh and uh Jiu Jitsu
magazine actually that was one of the
other techniques on on from that move
that you know we went over but what I
want people to understand is that it's
not based on on strength or athleticism
just like the 11 and 2 position
you know that you know that we have from
there you don't have to be strong Lee
could do it not Lee I promise you you
would find success with it and I think
he would you know I'm telling you yeah
absolutely it's changed completely I'm
not I'm not focusing on his hip anymore
that's the big difference Once I pass
that hip I don't see it again I'm not
focused on him it's a lot harder for him
to retain his guard he's got to go
138 [__] degrees Yeah Yeah it's
degrees it's not gonna happen the match
should end with either you keeping them
there or you tapping them and if I get
his head looking the other way with this
side of my gut
lights out and he's stuck there for a
couple minutes unless he's a a high
level blue belt I've been thrown to the
other way not yet but I've struggled
with them they've gained position some
way or outlasting me or whatever but
that's kind of we need the next chapter
yeah
we only run over one page yeah and not
even not even I know you got 29 I just
didn't want to saturate with you like
you know these video clips like they
figured I did you know I didn't you know
I need to hands up all that stuff really
yeah so much there's only so much I can
see on these videos that I'm putting out
to be honest with you I'm not putting
out like there most of them are a minute
and a half because I've done longer
videos in the past with the other
projects I've done and people they kind
of lose they lose their attention when
it's three minutes long it's like ah you
know it's too much but when I do little
Snippets I'm trying to build you know
I'm trying to take them down a road that
will build up an you know a game for
them and you know the thing is is it
just like with eleven and two you know
there's a lot of positions from guard
that are the same you know like they're
just is is Ironclad not they're not
going to get out you know once you have
them here and that's a whole deal once
you have them there then it's like okay
don't move a bunch just but you want is
you want someone when you approach them
and when you roll with him as soon as
you make contact
you connect
and that's just it like the they're
already in trouble you taught this thing
on one of the videos where even if they
sweep you
you have disconnected disconnected yes
because it's very interesting yeah they
say there's yeah connection is not
people are starting to get that more but
there's also disconnection and and you
know and the whole the whole Jiu Jitsu
library of things it's not about any one
particular thing it's it's it's about
all of them you know to you know the
connection disconnection framing you
know of course pressure course leverage
all it's all of the elements that you
hear about Jiu Jitsu because there's
there's many things that you do in the
game that's the beauty of Jiu Jitsu
there's it's so Dynamic but you got to
know when to do them at the right time
because that's where that's where a lot
of these these these people lose matches
and and I've like I was saying earlier I
I've actually you know like talked to
someone and you know and matches then I
go man you know what you're awesome
please don't stop you know because
they're like heartbroken because you can
tell they work so hard they put their
life on hold for two months for this
tournament and then they still came up
short and it was like you know what you
are so good you're actually better than
the other guy but you just did too much
you should have stopped right there you
you know you went to your mom and dad uh
you asked for twenty dollars they said
yes so then you kicked it up to 50 and
now they said I forget you're not
getting nothing that's what you did you
just you just took it a little too far
less is more and um you know you know
like I said
um earlier it's like uh you know I think
if I didn't have that you know this
hiccup with my neck which I've managed
to figure out more now
um I probably would still be trying to
like Crush people and slam people and
you know force force moves so it was a
blessing like when Bruce Lee in the
movie the end of the movie they [__]
made that story up he was in the
hospital crippled and he wrote the book
upside down and [__] well that's what
you did you you took the bad situation
and you turn it into something good
which a lot of people some people give
up some people turn into something else
that's the impression
no no no you know I watch your videos
and it's so weird how for the last two
years my secret hobby is watching the
Jiu-Jitsu videos I go from watching
matches you know I like [__] Gracie's
matches against the guy up in romulo and
I like that's one of my favorite matches
because it really taught me the real
Spirit of jujitsu it's very slow and
it's a pressure game and before I lose
this [__] weight you got to use this
weight and after you do 10 years a guy
that weighs 120 should weigh 200 on you
if he's doing the right [__] thing
you know I watched the Henry Atkins tape
yeah last week he talks about a pressure
game or something like that the lady Dr
Balise sent me one of his videos she
goes look at this pressure game thing
everybody has a different heart I'm
impressed with it
I'm impressed with I look at you guys
and I try to connect comedy to that like
I like how you're holding
our attention through Jujitsu you know
how hard that is for some people
actually watch somebody teach a move
there's a thousand arm bars type in
armbar on YouTube there's got to be 2
000 [__] pages of arm bars
and your videos stick out because you've
broke it down to a layman term like my
God I don't know what they're talking
about with wrestling I have no idea 531
000 videos
on the arm bar yeah what does that tell
you what does that tell you about this
[__] art that oh let's let's pretend
some of them are doubles oh yeah and
some of them are like Let's Pretend some
of them a trip well this is like a crazy
girl let's give it a low number let's
say a hundred thousand variations of
there's a thousand white Chinese
Brazilians martians people translating
their armbar well the hidden art of of
this game you know that we're talking
about is to do stuff that people don't
understand you know that they don't see
they don't that you know it's hard you
know the Jiu Jitsu stuff do you think
that I could have like okay if I hadn't
like grabbed and showed you the Mover
kind of you know positioning do you
think you would have caught on to it
without feeling it no that's the thing
it's like it's so hard to translate
stuff on video and like that's
you know that's the other thing that I'm
you know that I uh that I notice it's
like I'm putting videos out that one may
not be the flashiest so may get
overlooked
but I think the the the people that are
that are Maybe
you know paying attention to are the
ones that are wanting results you know
they're wanting results and they're
wanting to get past problems that
they're that they're running into that
realistically I've been there that's
that's a whole thing
when you talk about percentage
percentage Jiu Jitsu so we can break
this down for people
what's the best submission of the Year
this year
there's been yeah well one of them has
been Nate Diaz and what's the other one
Holly Holmes got submitted it's RNC yeah
right that's what that's where
everything should be going
you know the real naked joke it went
back to them you know Jiu-Jitsu 101.
well the three the three three most
famous performances that uh that I use
as an example and I hate the name drop
but you know the whole thing is you so
when I'm talking to my students that's
what I tell them if you're not going to
listen to me and that's fine you know
because every once in a while you'll
you'll you'll see younger guys are just
kind of like oh gosh should we go back
to the back takes and I go look it was
that uh what was the most iconic person
in Jiu Jitsu what's his main thing he
does you know well what do you see
Hixson do oh a lot of pitches have been
taken aback uh whenever John Jack had
his greatest performance what was he
doing now Abu Dhabi what did he do
what's his iconic picture I'm always
taking someone's back you know and then
that young kid that now is considered
pound for pound the best in the world
you know uh what was he doing what did
he do in Abu Dhabi and this is and you
know and you have people that are like
well
you know gee nogi what works you take
someone's back and you choke them and
that's Marcelo Garcia was the third one
so these you know so that's the whole
deal you know like
but realistically
it's not going to be
it's not something that has to be
complicated and the more complicated you
make it the more physical you make it
so look at Lee's on planet Jiu Jitsu
right now look at him he hasn't been
that high in [__] weeks yeah
it's I was wondering what
oh you're like most common questions are
the people get because like when I
started Jujitsu even though I had a
small wrestling background
I really had no
uh knowledge at all so I I would have
had a thousand questions so what like
what do you get most questions about
usually you had to get out of
submissions how to get out of like bad
positions like I'm stuck in a mountain
or how do you get out of a guillotine
how do you you know what so I think
because when people first start training
you know they feel frustrated in a sense
of they're getting beat up a lot but you
know there's certain simple things that
you can do that realistically they
negate everything that you know you're
having to deal with so whenever you
if you're in someone's Garden probably
one of the simplest things to do is
never put your hands above their Belt
Line because if your hands aren't above
their belt then you're out of range of
their attacks like all the submissions
that people do it's from things that are
in front of someone like if you are
looking at someone you're in their
Garden you know and you know when you
you put your hands on the belt right
that's going to keep your posture away
to the point where they can't reach your
neck enough to choke it so a lot of
people go for like the arms or the under
Hooks and you're saying that's a mistake
well if you're the top like you know I
think what happens is a lot of people
like you know when they first start in
Jiu Jitsu you know they end up in
someone's guard in someone's guard and
the person arm bars them their triangles
them or cross chokes them you know it
does all those things but all of all of
those things that they run into all of
those attacks they're only happening
because they're in they're in what we
call the strike zone okay so the strike
zone is the area from the person's belt
to their their chest and if you put your
hands anywhere in that area then you're
in target range for them to attack your
neck or or pull your arm across and go
for the arm or pull one over and go for
a triangle so you know that that's like
one concept just simple Strike Zone
Strike Zone and that negates all the
attacks that that everyone could can do
from your guard the other thing is you
know the positioning of your arms where
you have your arms framed but if someone
does a strike zone and then if that
fails they they frame their arms then
you know
they're not getting caught it's just the
percentage rate of of all the
submissions dropped down to 10 10
percent
so in a matter of fact most of the time
the when the person is going for the
submission they open up their guard and
that gives the person an opportunity to
go for a pass so that's the other thing
you you not only want to shut down or
negate their opportunities to attack but
you want every attack that they do to be
an opportunity for you to pass their
guard because when the legs are apart
the guard is open the windows are open
the only thing is that people
they maybe just don't get how their arm
is because if I go under underneath one
of your legs but I leave my arm out
reaching or it's slow and the person is
going to pull my arm and I'm back in
trouble again
so the simple fundamentals of jujitsu
you know they negate so many things I
look at it like this if you have a bunch
of blocks
and you stack them up
you know I'm not trying to knock all the
you know I want to get the one at the
bottom and pull that one and then all
the other ones fall on its own so you
know from from being in bad situations
at tournaments and you know and you know
I I'll admit it I've been put to sleep
you know in front of 20 students and I
learned I learned works on that listen
I'll never get put to sleep you can't
put people to sleep yeah well that's
what people you know I put
I put athletes on here before Fighters
uh
um you know and I and I like all of them
but I I I'm very intrigued with Jiu
Jitsu and the uh
one of those people that [__] uh the
translation of Jiu Jitsu it's either you
Eddie Bravo Marcelo Garcia
and for a guy like me that I would never
believe I'd walk into a jiu jitsu place
because I hate feet and I hate the smell
of rotten ass and all that [__] and
people sweating on me I don't even like
broad sweating them you only sweat I
mean one of me a monkey sweat that's it
nothing no other sweat do I want Uncle
Joey but
something about it intrigued me and I
and the reason why I have high level Jiu
Jitsu guys on the show is because you
know it showed me so many of my
weaknesses at an age when I didn't know
I had these weaknesses in so many levels
in so many levels mentally physically
and it made me work harder it made me
drink more water it made me make up uh
this morning I had a meeting I skipped
breakfast I had a protein a smoothie
with [__] fruit with almond milk then
I went to my meeting usually I would
have eggs at the house and bacon yeah
you make that almond milk proteins
it tastes like ass if you want me to sit
here and tell you every day is like I'm
shooting [__] dice I don't know what
I'm doing so good again if you put the
fresh fruit in it tastes like ass yeah
if you put the fresh fruit in and you
put the ice cream in and you smell the
blending like Jesus Christ what are they
putting in these [__] raspberries and
bananas so you got to mix it up a little
bit I take a couple CBD drops in my
tongue to strengthen my bones you know I
take a little baby aspirin to get my
heart going these are all the things I
was not doing before Jiu Jitsu as a 50
year old I was not looking at these
little things it opened up a world of
weaknesses for me that I had to conquer
for me to even make it to 60 which is
breathing
breathing anxiety and the world we live
in today brother what if
what if
what if two times Tony Uncle Joey Diaz
after not washing his ass after snorting
coke for [__] four weeks jumps you
from the bushes and gets on top of you
and you don't even know what's going on
in today's world everything that's going
into his [__] psyche
you know if you if you know how to
breathe and you lay on the floor and
breathe it out
and know that he doesn't have a knife
you have control of his leg something
something to give you a little security
Lee we had a discussion yesterday what
did you tell me what did you tell me he
was doing this week
every American this morning woke up and
re-evalli re-evaluated his life what
weapon they should get to me between you
and me
I would walk into a jiu jitsu school
today and reevaluate that weapon because
that's going to be the most important
weapon you know what if it's not Jiu
Jitsu if you don't want to lay on the
floor with fat dudes welcome to a karate
school
walking through a [__] anything any
type of martial art that'll teach you
when you hear that bullet to drop to the
floor
breathe hold on to your loved one and
maybe it'll get you out of that
situation
because I hope it doesn't keep happening
I don't I hope it doesn't happen here at
home but as a smart American you have to
assume it could happen at any time you
have to be unprepared now guys they
almost had an incident right yeah yeah
just this kid came in from there some 20
year old confused looking to suck dick
with a [__] grenade you know what I'm
saying yeah he was looking at walking
through a temple and say take my [__]
I'll give you all the weapons that poor
[__] bath is gay pride shove that
Arab dick in my muffler
hahaha
let me give some shout outs and get my
[__] Master out of here Ethan Buzzard
always dropping knowledge Sam Vega Jeff
taloman Tina shandini's Andrew nandala
they're in Nyack holding it down Kenny
Schaefer that Squad at me John Cutler my
main man [__]
spooky creepy weepy her cousin you know
everybody I love you [__] hope
you're doing well
I'm happy you came on today Doug this is
this is the dream come true this is
[__] tremendous see yeah like if I
die tomorrow I'm happy yeah no no no no
no I wanted you
you know man just uh you impressed the
[__] out of me you impressed the [__]
out of me because
we were talking earlier about uh you
know bad martial arts schools and good
martial arts schools and what you should
be getting from them and again I'm going
on the Spectrum here I'm going on the
spectrum between whether you want to
join karate savat Muay Thai
sometimes you go in there for to get
into shape which is I what I like going
I wanna but I also start going over
there to overcome my fears
I had so much fear Jiu Jitsu being on
the bottom and not knowing how to get
out of the mountain what am I going to
do and now I know at least to breathe
and I throw my arm over and spin and the
guy I throw them off balance and I'm
working with a deep half you know I have
a path now you know when it and I think
once you have a path it gives you more
confidence but it gives you more
confidence outside that like I'd say a
thousand times a day
I'm a little older and by the time five
o'clock comes I'm shot in my mind you
know is out there I got a wife the kid
the whole [__] podcast what weekend
where am I going I gotta get a plane
ticket
I can't do Jiu Jitsu at night but what I
really like about going in the daytime
is that when I walk out of that my day
has changed my outlook has changed uh
whatever I thought was going to be a
struggle is no longer a struggle because
the toughest thing I'm gonna do that I
just did
10 hip escapes is [__] murder you
know what I'm saying would I rather get
on stage and crack jokes for five
minutes or do 10 hip escapes I do comedy
for 10 hours instead of doing 10 hip
escapes but the 10 hip escapes are a lot
better for me and it's gonna make my
comedy a lot stronger
so I appreciate you guys man from the
bottom of my heart I appreciate you guys
you driving down here and teaching me on
a Sunday where you could have been with
your family I know you're a Christian
man and I respect that with all my heart
that's why I put you on the show and
mostly because of your belief of what
you're doing
how
anybody could teach Jiu Jitsu from 100 a
month you know you're doing the
periscopes you're doing the video it
shows us you got something you got balls
you're a Jehovah Witness without
knocking down doors you know what I'm
saying even yeah be careful saying that
no I know I know they'll come back and
get you like the Scientologist now
they'll send people to your house three
times a day they'll even knock on the
back door
not well it's it I think you know you
stay in the game you're you know it
becomes an art and um you know it's like
now I'd like to see people succeed and I
like to you know
nice people I should say
it's nice when you see a little guy that
you know conquers a mountain and then
you know when it happens that's that's
more rewarding than anything you know as
far as money goes you know so
that's what I want to do how can people
get a hold of you Tarzan before you
choke the death well you first of all I
was laughing and it went down the wrong
pipe so it's your fault Christ so mighty
unbelievable okay hang on one second
Lee how you doing over there all right
you're seeing Devils no you're all good
yeah I'm doing good thank you for doing
that so all right
as far as me not catching all the noise
I was making so he's a good dog
yeah yeah he's sharpest look how easy
shaved he's ready to [__] Rockets
we're just leaving for how long she
leaving
should be gone for two weeks in like
August oh you'll be lost I have to smack
you around one of those nights you'll be
here crying worrying she's talking to
some French tourists and [__] talking
wee-wee and [__]
you'll be all worried scratching you'll
get us you get a rash over your eyeball
again like you got that's cool like you
gotta jacuzzi you just got one how did
you get yours the [__] the stye oh I
don't know I don't know I think I
[__] didn't wipe my ass and maybe I
wiped my ass and clean my eyeball or
something I don't know
that's how you have [__] on your fingers
you put salt on your eye and you put a
[__] steak and you go to bed the next
morning you wake up you're back to being
Clark Gable
[__] are you kidding you know what I'm
saying where can these people find you
is there a web page um well that hit me
okay hit me Tarzan give me the paperwork
over there Thursday thank you sir do you
need the death desire
no I got that the the the information
that they can see a lot of stuff on is
the Jiu Jitsu Revolution
so trujitsu spelled without an e so it's
Tru
j-i-t-s-u so that Jiu Jitsu Revolution
um you know like you mentioned Periscope
you know I if they look up at Matt Baker
BJJ that's a handle a true Jitsu is a
periscope but I do a lot of question and
answers and stuff like that I just you
know
the more when questions come in I make a
point put together a national time get
back to me yeah and I'll blow it up on
here so you have a national time every
night yeah if it's 15 minutes much
bigger comes on like red or hit them
teach them show them right off back this
is why I love you I'm gonna show you why
I really love you before you [__]
leave red or back red on round ball way
before you're a young man too Matt Baker
way before you and it's in your daddy's
pants okay
there was a team called the Boston
Celtics and they won a bunch of
championships and the guy who won the
Championships the coach his name was red
all back do you know anything about this
no man yeah he was a white dude who
smoked a cigar and America fell in love
with me he was great but he was very
fundamentally sound
and when the NBA or the ABA
I don't know don't [__] correctly I
don't know if they merged the one on
whatever the [__] happened the NBA you
know had all these [__] Sensational
players
so they went after uh you know Sundays
the same way Football goes after Sunday
dang that's a big TV
right right there that one okay so this
guy would come on look at this [__] on
Sundays and he would do this at halftime
okay this is what you're doing on
YouTube put the volume on he would do it
half time this guy here is where from my
boy Theo Von is from that's cool this is
pistol look at him that's you Matt Baker
[Music]
the greatest playmaker playing today
the great passer great shooter but a lot
of people don't know this
He is wonderful in all these dexterity
drills look at this look at this this is
you 20 years ago it comes out of a
system I started hugging you right now
for seven years what we call homework
basketball and takes in reactions listen
improve your quickness your coordination
your confidence and your overall ability
to handle a basketball bro well actually
don't you get the feeling that when
you're doing these things the ball
becomes sort of an extension of your
hand exactly that's exactly how it felt
learning new types of drills to dribble
with one ball with two balls and so
forth that uh I never really had to look
at the basketball when I dribbled it
which improved my game from because this
following [__] beat him and if he
didn't win he put him in the [__]
shed Pistol Pete man he drank himself to
death that poor bastard
that was my [__] hero that white dog
and some of the things that look at what
this guy would do in a [__] cold
[__]
show us Pete watch what Pete was doing a
cold by himself just to improve my
quickness is what I call a Ricochet
drill are you staying with your feet
apart and just throw the ball down back
and forth like this this is really just
for coordination purposes
and then once you get into what I call
the bullet Rickshaw where you Buckle the
ball yeah you know you do that three
times yeah that'd be cool to put yeah
if you understand what this meant to me
when I was a kid but now I would get the
basketball immediately Bam Bam my mom
will come a whole San Antonio don't
break the dishes you know what I'm
saying because I would go crazy this was
my life when I was a kid he played it
this is this was for 15 [__] hours
for four minutes look at this this is
brilliant they don't do this no more
this is what the UMC should be doing and
you're doing it for free in the
summertime but the object is to put the
ball I did all this [__]
object of this drill is to clap your
hands in front and catch the ball before
it hits the ground
requires a lot of mental concentration
and I don't know if I'll be able to get
it but I'll try
what this dude yeah
yeah probably tried pretty good didn't
he how about a couple more Pete well I
could take two balls and show us short
drill which is just a short figure eight
drill using two basketballs
what we call in Rhythm and algorithm
then going around
I did this [__] for hours in my backyard
like a [__] that's ADB right there you
see a kid doing that you shoot him
but that was me
ball is from the ground don't you feel
real superior to the next guy knowing
that you could he's giving away like low
position genius knowledge genius yeah
just this people as an individual is
putting the ball out in front of us
thanks for bringing this up that's kind
of inspiring dribble back over like that
giving up Jiu Jitsu I'm gonna play
basketball
you know what you do for me right there
on a Sunday every kid was in the house
in my name every basketball player was
home right now and as soon as this ended
you got that ball and ran to the court
to do what they were doing that's what
you do with people today
same difference
well
this stuck with me for life I'd never
forget this right on Rambo every time I
got an MMA guy in here a jiu jitsu
Professor a master a karate man I say
this is the [__] nobody's doing this
keep telling yourself how can this help
my game
so you can work on it hard knowing Pedro
has more ideas
this is what I'm talking about old
school [__] right that's what I
yeah that's what I want to do and that's
you know well hey I gotta say this thank
you very much for letting me be on your
show please
I wish we started rolling back in
December like or we had a little thing I
almost yeah I almost made bump into him
so but he had his matching happened here
I wanna let me tell the sponsors and
we'll get you out of here I know you got
a long ride you're teaching a class
tonight you're a man of them
you're you're flying everywhere man
you're you're just doing too many
awesome things no I'm just trying to put
the pieces together first of all the
show's also always sponsored by audit I
love these [__] you know when I
get off a plane after a two-hour [__]
sleep I pop one of those Alpha brains at
least it holds me over to the afternoon
it focuses me to staple everything and
put all the bills and stack I put my
clothes in the laundry you know it gives
me that energy man and the shroom Tech
I'm not sick you know I I fly twice a
[__] week I'm in a plane with a
thousand [__] people Japanese people
with mask on you know I'm gonna start
wearing a [__] mask on a plane these
[__] [__] anyway on it.com right now
go look at the great selection of
supplements they got they're gonna give
you 10 off your your first order and you
know what they're delivered right to
your house stop [__] around with your
life I'm telling you right now the Hem
Force milkshakes the protein shakes the
the the the shroom Tech sport the shroom
Tech immune not to mention the [__]
Alpha Brain which they give you 100
money back guaranteed
no questions asked stop [__] lying to
yourself and get yourself on track [__]
suckers all right number two
they sent me a package and I'll tell you
what
that's usara
I love what they sent me I they have a
great selection of hemp products strong
I mean Dr Sarah means what Lee do you
remember loyal people working it don't
matter what it means let me tell you
something this is a great brand that bag
they sent me I got they sent me a water
bottle that fits right in there I put my
my nasal spray and my my things and the
other the the the sweat towels I got in
one pocket I put the the protein powder
and a bag in I put it in there and then
the other thing I put the regular
container of water just so I could put
the protein powder in there so after I
get off the mat in the bag they gave me
a little bag that I could put my dirty
rash guard and my sweaty [__]
underwear and then so I have to drive
home and like at least I have to take a
shower show them my little Cuban
uncircumcised dick in my fungi toe to
all the guys at the gym okay the bag is
[__] listen guys go to what's the web
page
dsgear.com that's D capital S capital
gear.com go look at the Great they got a
fanny pack I got everything in there I
flew this week like a [__] doctor and
I [__] up I told him I was going to
take a picture and email to him and I
forgot that you know I feel creepy going
up to people and I'm gonna take a
picture of me at the airport with a
nappy sack on a uh what do you calling
me
the front pact I gave you what do you
call it they're um the fanny packs the
fanny pack that Rogan talked about on
the podcast when we were on there but
that's usaw is a great brand the ghee is
[__] tremendous it means to leave the
salary worker's life you hear what I'm
saying this is the way Chris thinks to
leave the salary what is it it's no
glasses it's a Japanese uh word that
translates literally to the to leave the
salary worker life okay that's what I'm
talking about listen go to go to
dsgear.com right now look at the great
selection from the ghee they have to the
bag I I'm telling you right now the back
they had a they have a hooded sweatshirt
that is tremendous it feels like so
often and it feels great you know it's
just got hot now I can't be walking
around with a black uh hooded squirt
next thing you know I'm getting shot in
the [__] neck you know what I'm
saying so anyway go to dsgear.com right
now whether it's a bag you want a fanny
pack listen I don't give a [__] what
they say I got weed in my fanny pack I
got rolling papers in my fanny pack I
got [__] uh a vapor pen in my fanny
pack and you know what
it went through security don't tell them
I told you because then the [__]
you'll put the feds on to me [__]
anyway go to dsgear.com anything they
have on there type in church Joey Joey
j-o-e-y and get five percent off okay
dsgive.com right now Preston Joey and
get five percent off I'm taking carrying
and they'll ship it to you the whole
[__] deal tell them I sent you all
right and number three I want to welcome
to the show
one of the [__] best I'm hearing
nothing but great things Lee what do you
think when you use them tell me the
[__] truth geek and it's great it's
great for for two things if you know
where you want to go you can just type
it in like okay I want to go see the
Dodgers or whatever but it's I liked it
because I was new in town and they have
every if you when you put in your city
you can just scroll through and you're
like oh these people are here oh these
people are here and it's really cool and
I also like it because
like it shows you like where in what row
your seat like it's like you can like
you'll actually see where you're sitting
in some places and like uh you can see
by color where the more expensive
I went and saw the Dodgers a couple
times and I went and saw a play I went
and saw um what uh what was the uh
The Book of Mormon look at you yeah no
it's great see what I'm saying seek geek
have you ever been frustrated trying to
buy tickets online guys yeah most sites
make it complicated then they try to
sneak into huge freezer checkout that's
why you need to try seek geek
c-a-t-g-e-e-k that made it easier than
ever to buy and sell Sport and concert
tickets okay Lee told you how great they
were seat geek has taken over the work
and asked a lot of shopping for tickets
seat geek post all the tickets available
on other sites into one place so you
save time and never miss a deal even
better every ticket on safety is given a
grade based on value so you can
immediately find unpriced seats and
before you buy you can use seek Geeks
detail Maps like Lee said to see the
view from your seat
best of all sea geek is always honest
and upfront about the price all right
unlike StubHub seat geek shows you the
full ticket price from start to finish
no surprises no by the ways with a huge
fees at checkout all right now listen
what I'm doing for you I'm gonna give
you my listeners get a 20 rebate off
their first seat geek purchase twenty
dollars off the first seat geek purchase
here we go to get your 20 rebate on
ticket download the free seek geek app
go to the settings tab and click add
promo code again go to the settings tab
and click add promo code enter promo
code Church c h u r c h seek equal send
you twenty dollars after you've made
your first ticket purchase download the
free seek geek app and enter promo code
church today not tomorrow but there's a
lot of great things happening this
summer there's great contents coming to
your town you always want to see a good
baseball and your family right now go to
seek geek
what happened
that let me see geek app and enter promo
code church right but let's download the
free sick geek app and go to settings
tab in and click add promo code and
enter the promo code church it's that
easy so let me just for an example I
mean we're in Los Angeles so the first
thing I open up Los Angeles Angels
tickets from three dollars
Los Angeles Sparks tickets from six
dollars
uh
let's see who is here the Dodgers
tickets from two dollars Bob Dylan's
here
uh
DMX is here if you want to see DMX so
yeah that just shows you you can follow
different people to leave quilly is here
but that's 19 plus so
but yeah I mean it's pretty cool go to
download the seat geek app right now and
the promo code at the promo code Church
CH u r c h again I'd like to thank Dr
sarik and I'd like to thank onit.com for
sponsors I like to thank Matt Baker at
Matt Baker BJJ up there in Bakersfield
if you're in the area drop in he'll
[__] talk to your teacher and move on
the arm all right that's how we roll
thank you for having me tremendously
thank you for doing what you do my
brother you're a true it's a privilege
martial art Master on the John jog the
Lord that saves us you're a Savage Lee
take it [__] hit it with some
we're gonna play some nice Christian
music for me right now I discovered this
band in 1987 when I done my little stent
in prison with these Christian Brothers
and never play this while we would pray
oh my
you used to listen to this at ramrods or
no
I got this in Boulder Colorado
I had just gotten married and I brought
this [__] cassette home and I played
it for my then wife uh just looked at me
with a look of [__] disdain yeah and
then I brought it to my job and those
white people went [__] nuts
oh my
oh
I can't help us to look at the video
oh [__]
you ever see an Asian chick like a
Filipino chick and you look at them and
think of this song all beat up oh [__]
[__] up feet
oh [__]
that's just awful let's just beat up
Filipinos
when he knew I got that ass
oh
all right it's not a mystery what was my
game yeah oh [__]
he's crawling on the floor like a dog
have you heard the song the motherload
no
this is too this still gets me this
still gets me every time Lisa I still
Giggle and [__] I think it gets
better every time I
love it I love it
oh
wait for it
that was uh
[Music]
think
I worked in a country bar
with a big fan yes they were and
everyone would sing every line until it
got to that one sentence and then all
the the girls would like not say it it
was like
that was just too far I'll tell you that
we're going out
never to the movies just straight to my
house
you said it yourself
you like it like I do
put your lips on my pipe
oh my God I'm a dog in heat oh [__] a
frequency
oh [__] thank you that was funny oh
so this is